i OS 13 is installed I have dark mode
enabled and now I'm going to make my
first an emoji first I'm gonna make one
that looks like me and then I'm going to
show you guys some of the crazy
customizations that you can do you can
basically make yourself look like
anything but first let me make a meme og
of myself okay so I've got my skin tone
like you can really get wild feel like
my hair is a little bit less belong that
it used to be a part is on the wrong
side you need to be able to switch your
hair part this is like overwhelming what
I guess I'm gonna go with simple and
basic there it is
couldn't get any more basic than that my
eyebrows are a little bit darker than my
hair I always thought that I had green
eyes but my mom recently told me that
they weren't really that green so I'm
gonna go with this like two-tone color
like that's actually pretty accurate to
what I think that did look like if I was
a child this is what I look like I guess
this is me now this is me
after WWDC III and all the activities
that are happening in June this is gonna
be me we have a very pointy chin because
you guys like to point that out to me
quite often where are you gonna stab
somebody with that yes that's ok nose
small thick hmm look at that I think I
always wanted to get my nose pierced but
I never have I always thought like a
cute little diamond would be very very
endearing wow this is all new ok wait
let me pick my lips first I think I'm
not really gener status but like even go
to that's a little too aggressive
I know let's read I do love a good
purple lip I think that's good I like
super basic this is interesting
you can have people definitely don't
miss braces I actually do have two fake
teeth but they're down here you can't
really tell mouth piercings this looks
so cute
not very pain tolerant so I don't think
I can handle it tongue piercing no way
that's something that I never wanted to
do ears let's try the ears you can see
my can't see my ears so I'll just take a
small ear earrings look at all these
earrings options wow wow wow okay I love
like a rose gold two colors I feel like
that's kind of nice that's not really
rose gold though that could look like
diamonds I like super simple just like a
little stud that's me you can't even see
it anyway audio this is cool so they
also have like a hearing aid and he also
got ear pods you better believe I'm
putting air pods anyway you can't see it
maybe I shake my head oh you can pick
the audio position if you lost one of
your air paws for example facial hair
and mustache i mustache you a question
don't really have any facial hair so
there are a lot of facial hair option
it's like a look at these incredibly it
is like endless whoa okay the old
eyewear I actually have these glasses
they're Arabians oh yes these are great
you guys don't often see me wear glasses
but these are like exactly my glasses
look at all of these options so
[Music]
you're normally our contacts this is
really starting to look like me and it's
kind of freaking me out a little
it's just like a little bit but I don't
normally wear glasses so we'll just how
do I take them off an eyepatch option
like this is so incredibly customizable
that I feel like they have taken so many
things into account and Apple I applaud
you that has got three something that's
so difficult to be so inclusive to
everyone there's all kinds of headwear
this it's just incredible I mean I'm so
impressed like they even have my crown
here ready for me to wear I can take
that off there is so much more that I
missed I didn't even realize this was
here you can scroll down and continue to
customize like this is I didn't even
realize this so usually I do like a
light little eyeliner so this this does
that look like we need is this look like
me I'm having a problem I like to see
who can make the best version of me add
more eyeliner okay I could spend way too
much time oh my goodness I even missed
this the cheeks we cannot forget my
excessive amount of blush that I like to
wear mmm I missed all of this stuff now
I'm starting to I have a beauty spot
I've got one right here but they don't
can't add it you got to add two more
look there's two more spots we need one
here and here
it's freckles to add this is really fun
and I'm really enjoying this I think
this is really starting to look like me
I think I'm not sure I think I'm too
close to it like actually ghouls do it I
don't know I think this looks good I
think I need to stop before I start
getting really crazy I think this is
gonna be my final look well it has to be
oh my gosh the stickers oh it's so great
oh I'm having so much fun I'm having so
much fun already
oh this is incredible this isn't this is
me all the time all the time facepalm I
love it I freaking love it this is so
much less creepier
then like the Android creepy hey Jenna I
just wanted to say hi this is my new
meme oh gee I hope that you like it I
spent way too much time on it
so let me know he got a little mouse but
yeah these are the stickers these are
really cool oh I can edit my own I
didn't realize that you could do that
which is great if you go into your
stickers and then you scroll all the way
down at the bottom you can you can edit
it so that's great
because I thought that once I hit save
it was permanent oh this is fun
definitely kind of makes me look like
I've had a little bit of work done he's
I didn't think I look like Hillary
Clinton she's not saying anything like I
need a little bit of like ello that but
hey Pig right Mac tell me that I'm
beautiful she's not even giving me any
attention so I guess this is it this is
this is the me bow geez now I'm gonna go
through and make one that's kind of
really crazy what I wish that I was so I
can make both of my ears have different
earrings this looks so good that I've
already to go get my ears pierced
tonight yeah look at that you can see my
ear pods so many facial hair but if I do
want some sideburns
I probably shouldn't I think I look good
oh boy no way I can also change the
colors of my lenses oh I think we're
gonna go back with the pink because
we've got a theme going on obviously I
don't need head wear because I have a
mohawk and you won't be able to see this
beautiful beautiful creation well that's
it I think we did it so Jen is ignoring
me but that's okay I'm gonna ask for
what she thinks of this one hi Jenna
okay so what do you think I've got a lip
piercing I've got a knife here sting
I've got some really cool glasses I also
surprised have my tongue pierced I love
it but look at his mohawk doesn't
oh it's it's lovely why is she ignoring
me hey Pig why are you ignoring me ah oh
oh my that was the biggest troll like my
heart it is on the floor right now I
just peed myself thinking that I was
sending this all to that is not funny at
all I got honestly I think I peed myself
like I am I definitely peed myself out
of being terrified that I said this the
wrong person you're not funny
so I've been using this beta build for
about a day now and so far it's been
pretty stable I didn't install it on my
main device this is on my iPhone @nr of
course I have an iPhone tennis max here
which I have not installed it on but now
it's so weird going back to this and
seeing light mode it is so different I'm
pretty excited for iOS 13 there are so
many fun features if you guys have a
favorite feature in iOS 13 I would love
to hear what it is in the comments below
dark mode is so far one of my favorite
things like it just really it's just so
much easier on the eyes so that's all
for now I will see you guys in my next
video I so many fun videos coming out
for you guys this week so if you guys
aren't subscribed already be sure to hit
subscribe also make sure even if you are
subscribed to hit the bells you guys
will be notified when I post new videos
make sure you get all notifications
because I have a bunch of fun stuff
coming up this week I don't want you
guys to miss it so with that I'll see
you guys later
[Music]